alright guys I just got my order
yesterday for the v-cube 6 & 7 that I
got from D cubes calm in case you were
wondering I ordered it on June 24th and
I got it yesterday which was the 7th so
that took roughly 13 days including the
processing and the shipping the shipping
itself took four days and was by DHL for
those of you who don't know what V cubes
are that the new cubes created by the
Greek engineer Panaji Otis Valdez and he
has basically created the first working
models of cubes that have more than five
layers which was previously thought to
be impossible so the cubes have not been
officially released yet however they
will be in September of this year in
Greece the cubes I bought were the V
Cube six and seven I did not purchase a
V Cube five however I heard mixed
opinions about it the majority of them
were good though they said it was the
best of the three and it turned the best
however a few said it really wasn't
worth the price and you might as well
just keep an east gene or Rubik's to do
cube whatever you have I will most
likely by the vq5 at some point just to
have the collection but I was really
eager to get my hands onto the six and
seven which are probably the most
anticipated cubes because there these
are basically the first of their kind
there's no other six and sevens out
right now so I'm going to give a review
of the cubes however I will not be
solving it in this video I will have
speed solving videos hopefully later on
depending on how fast I can solve them
since I really have not gotten the
chance to solve the six and seven that
much besides on gabba soft which is not
really as easy as a real cube so I'm
also going to save you the time of
taking them out of the package like a
lot of other people have been doing and
I'm just going to basically show them to
you
they were packaged in a bag and
basically the boxes were just in the bag
like that and they were covered in
plastic so they were kind of a little
bit loose but it's alright so to start
off I'm going to give you a 360 degree
view of the cubes and I'm going to
demonstrate what they can do and I'm
going to also give a short review of how
I think they can work basically I I've
been playing with them since yesterday
I've got to solve it a few times so I
you know what I think all right so this
is the V cube 6 it weighs 316 grams or
about 0.7 pounds it is actually one gram
heavier than the V cube 7 is most likely
because of the internal mechanism that
it has however it does seem to be a
pretty good weight it doesn't feel too
heavy or anything like that in the hand
and as far as the size it's about the
same size as a Rubik's Cube professor
this is 7 centimeters and this is 6.9 so
they're pretty close in size so if you
want a good comparison you could take a
look at a Rubik's Cube professor the
overall look of the cube is nice I like
the white plastic with the black
stickers it gives it a nice contrast the
color scheme of the rest of the cube is
identical to the Rubik's brand so
opposite of the red you have the orange
opposite of the green you have the blue
and opposite of the yellow in this case
we have the black instead of the white
as far as the structure of the cube it
seems relatively sturdy it does have a
screw holding everything together on
each side it is a little bit loose most
likely because it has a spring inside
that allows these layers to be somewhat
flexible as rotation is concerned as far
as rotation it does seem to have some
sort of snapping mechanism that allows
these layers to kind of click into place
seems to snap like 4 times per 90 degree
turn I don't know if you guys can hear
that but it's basically snaps at each
90-degree turn it clicks one of the
unique things I saw about the V cube 6
was its ability for these inside layers
to kind of turn independently of the top
layer so I've never seen that in any
other cube usually if you have a Rubik's
professor and you try to turn the inside
layer here the top layer will come along
with it you're not going to be able to
turn that layer by itself with one
finger so that I thought that was pretty
unique so the the overall turning is not
quite you know the smoothest that you'll
see however I feel that it should get
better
once you solve it a few times the
snapping mechanism is actually not bad
it allows you to kind of align the
layers a little bit better before
turning them however you got to be
careful because the the centerpiece is
here the center edge pieces will pop if
you're not too careful but the cube can
cut corners pretty nicely other than
that I think a little bit of breaking
the Kuban should should be good and you
should be able to get some pretty good
speed cubing times with it all right so
this is the V cube 7 as I said before it
weighs one gram less than the V cube 6
does which makes it a pretty decent
weight for its size it doesn't really
feel heavy at all because the cube is
obviously a little bit larger it's it
says 72 millimeters on the site I
believe that is from corner to corner
edge to edge it's about 77 millimeters
so the larger size does require that you
expand your hand a little bit and it
takes a little bit of getting used to
overall I like the look of the cube I
think it looks nice the pillow shape
makes it look nice as well makes it look
a little futuristic even though it's
basically for stability issues any cube
larger than 6x6 has to have that
pillowing shape otherwise it won't be
stable enough upon close inspection I
did notice that some of these outer
corner I'm sorry outer edge pieces they
did have some spacing in them it's not
that big of a deal and I tried to
squeeze them together but I think it's
pretty stable the way it is I don't
think it's really a problem the
structure overall is extremely sturdy I
mean I'm I'm pulling on that basically
as hard as I can and it doesn't really
move up here it does have a little bit
of give which is good because it allows
it to turn very well the the rotation is
extremely smooth and you can cut corners
like no problem at all
so I mean it is it is extremely stable
and it also sounds pretty nice as well
you might have seen everyone trying to
do the checkerboard pattern that's
basically just to show that each of
these layers turns pretty well with one
another I mean there's no like caching
in between any of these layers each of
them turns pretty well next to each
other so I think I think the cube
overall is really a masterpiece I think
it's a great cube probably I mean I know
some people are probably going to try to
duplicate the six and seven cubes but I
would say that this is going to be the
best one out it is a great cube I would
say for speed cubing there's really no
problems with this cube at all
occasionally I mean if you do try to cut
it if you try to cut it like that
obviously you're going to get some
pieces so that they're jammed but I
haven't had a situation where one of the
pieces has popped yet and I solved it
two times basically but it took me a
little while so I got to get used to
solving the bigger cubes as well overall
I think it's a really great cube so I
kind of like it a little bit better than
the 6x6 cube but I like them both
alright guys so for some final thoughts
on the B cube 6 and the B cube 7 I'm
going to have to say that of the - I
like the V cube 7 better it's just a
really nice design it's well made it is
stable smooth and durable there's really
not that much that I could say is wrong
with the V cube 7 it's pretty close to
perfection
as far as the V cube 6 is concerned I'm
not going to nitpick on small things
like the clicking of the layers it's
really not that big of a deal and you
get used to it and I'm sure that when
you solve it many more times it'll
probably not feel as clicky it'll
probably get worn in a little bit you
just have to break it in probably
but what kind of is annoying is the fact
that the pieces do pop out quite
frequently when your speed solving you
got to be careful in order to prevent
that from happening but it does happen
and you have to sit there the pieces you
know they fly out you got to pick them
up put them back in it's just a little
bit annoying other than that I think
that just the v-cube six is also a good
a good cube for speed solving I don't
think it should give that much problems
and like I said I think that it will get
better as you solve it more um both of
the cues are really well made overall I
would have to say that both of them are
worth the buy if you're going to buy it
to solve it by to collect it whatever if
you enjoy solving big cubes even with
the high price tag you might want to go
with both of them if you have to get one
then you're probably definitely going to
want to get the V Cube seven it's just
really a really well-made cube it's not
really any problems with the V Cube
seven at all alright guys so I probably
will have some speed solving videos
depending on how fast I am able to
eventually solve the cubes so you can
check out my channel at youtube.com
slash Rob h20 six to nine take care